então boa tarde a todos
eu vim aqui hoje apresentar uma doença é
a síndrome nefrótica em crianças e
adolescentes
uma das principais doenças renais na
infância sendo que as crianças quando
apresentam essa doença elas vão perdendo
progressivamente a função de seus rins e
vão combinar por uma insuficiência renal
sendo que a única solução para elas é um
transplante renal
mas eu vim aqui dar uma boa notícia a
notícia de que quando identificamos
mutações no dna dessas crianças elas
podem ter um benefício após transplante
renal se comparado com crianças que não
apresentem as mutações
então essas mesmas mutações que são a
causa da doença dessas crianças podem
beneficiá las quando a gente encontra
essas mutações porque elas vão ter uma
maior chance de resposta depois do
transplante
então eu espero que vocês consigam
entender eu vou tentar ser bem simples
bom eu não posso falar dessa história
sem contar um pouco da minha história
quando eu tinha 19 anos eu era um
estudante eu queria fazer faculdade e na
unicamp
eu queria fazer biologia quando eu
comecei a acordar pela manhã com os
olhos bem fechados e no cursinho meus
amigos tirar uns armar a nossa se chorou
muito noite inteira brincou namorado
porque meu olho estava inchado mesmo era
bem evidente sem chance
só que infelizmente não é uma coisa boa
né então uma amiga da minha mãe nos
alertou de que podia ser um problema
renal eu tive que ficar um mês em
repouso absoluto e daí começou uma
procura aos médicos na então eu comecei
a partir do edema eu também aprendi eu
fiquei sabendo que meu e demora no corpo
inteiro não era só nos olhos e após um
exame de urina foi detectado que tinha
proteínas na urina eu nem sabia que não
existe a proteína na urina na época
agora eu já sei mas as proteínas devem
ficar no sangue
elas não podem ser eliminadas pelas
nossa culinária bom o médico fez uma
biópsia renal que guarda a marca até
hoje aqui e após a biópsia e
recebi o diagnóstico de romero esclerose
segmentar e focal em fase inicial
esse nome não me dizia nada mas eu
entendia que eu estava perdendo a função
dos meus rins e que falaram pra mim meus
pais que provavelmente em 4 ou 5 anos eu
perderia a função dos meus rins e teria
que receber um transplante
imaginem como foi essa reação pra mim eu
fiquei arrasada foi muito difícil até
hoje me emociono ao falar porque há a
sensação de vocês a pensar que pode
perder a vida é uma coisa muito forte né
mas ao contrário do que era esperado no
meu caso eu tive sucesso então mim é
minha vida voltou ao normal em quatro ou
cinco anos ao contrário do que o médico
falou foi um caso atípico mas na verdade
a maioria dos casos essas crianças elas
vão evoluindo mesmo para transplante
então elas têm sintomas que são a
proteína quero que apresentava o edema e
esses outros dois sintomas e eu vou
tentar mostrar pra vocês aqui hoje como
que a partir da proteína dura vão
acontecendo os outros sintomas e como
que mutações no dna podem ajudar tá ok
então só pra gente lembrar nós temos
dois rins eles filtram o nosso sangue e
à urina formada levada pelos critérios
até a bexiga até ela vai sendo
armazenada até a próxima missão
se a gente fizer um corte longitudinal
aqui de um dos rins
a gente encontra essa estrutura interna
e na superfície
existem 1 1 milhão de unidades de uma
unidade que é chamada de nephron 1
milhão em cada um dos nossos rins é
muito né
essa é essa unidade é que nessa região
menor aqui que acontece a filtração
propriamente dita
nessa região onde o sangue vai entrando
dentro dos rins e um dos goleiros que é
nomeado para esse novelo de capilares
acontece a situação propriamente dita
então o sangue entra lá número no ele é
filtrado e retorna para a circulação
sendo que a urina é formada nesse local
zinho verde que a gente pode observar e
é nessa estrutura que é chamada de
barreira de filtração glomerular que
parece uma peneira que acontece a outra
são então nós temos na alimentação a
gente recebe para os nutrientes e esses
nutrientes têm que ficar dentro da
peneira
eles não podem passar a urina certo se
passa alguma coisa está errada então
somente água e pequenos solutos passamos
a nossa urina
esse vídeo mostra que acabei de falar
então o sangue entrando em um dos
governos aqui uma representação lógico
sendo que essas paredes não dá pra ver
que a olho nu mas existem pequenos poros
onde pequenas moléculas podem passar mas
células maiores e proteínas não passam
elas ficam no sangue
tá então hemácias células de defesa não
passa somente o que vai se formar
a urina então esse esquema eu desenhei é
um esquema de um capilar e o ngoma
arcuri no já filtrada do lado
então é importante entender esse esquema
porque aonde tem essa parede que divide
os dois lados
essa é a parede que que a gente chama de
barreira existem células
importantíssimas alex são os propósitos
elas quando estão intactas não permitem
que proteínas que essa bolinha preta
aqui ó pá 100 sendo que a proteína
principal é albina
tá então essas com a estrutura também
está com uma intacta tudo bem mas isso
essa estrutura estiver danificada ocorre
é o seguinte a passagem de proteínas na
urina que é o que está acontecendo no
meu caso e aqui é o que acontece com as
crianças então começam a perder proteína
pela urina certo mas o nosso sangue ele
possui então essas proteínas que são
albumina principalmente eu abomino ela
tem que ficar lá no sangue se a gente
perde a proteína que acontece no nosso
sangue não está só aqui no goleiro
nossos rios né
o nosso sangue riga todos os tecidos se
o sangue tem diminuição daquela
concentração é o que vai acontecer então
esse é um esquema de um capilar imagine
um só capilar e irrigando um tecido
específico então nós temos por exemplo
aqui um órgão com a pele né
então nós temos nas células em baixo
aqui essas bolas grandes em cima
o sangue com o plasma e um líquido que
permeia essas células que está ali entre
o tecido e eu capilar
esse líquido possui uma composição muito
parecida com a do plasma moléculas de
açúcar oxigênio dióxido de carbono
várias moléculas água e e a única
diferença então é a presença dessas
proteínas que são as bolinhas pretas né
essas proteínas que são apenas
principalmente alumina ela faz com que a
água fique no capilar
quando você tem diminuição das bolinhas
duas proteínas a água consegue escapar
lhe dos capilares
então é isso que eu represento aqui
nesse esquema os capilares e o fluido
agora desse lado não não mais a urina tá
então fui intersticial né do nosso corpo
então se a gente tem diminuição das
proteínas que estão retendo as moléculas
de água e as proteínas estão sendo
perdidas pela urina ocorre a passagem de
água pro espaço intersticial e esse é o
edema então as crianças ficam com os
olhos inchados a perna inchada além dos
médicos apalpando a minha perna porque
nós ficamos realmente com acúmulo de
água no nosso organismo
então os primeiros dois sintomas estão
compreendidos e como mimi a diminuição
da urina e no sangue já que nós perdemos
proteína pela urina e a
hipercolesterolemia é uma concentração
relativa do colesterol porque nós temos
um equilíbrio abomina a outras moléculas
lipídios entre eles o colesterol no
sangue
perdeu abomina relativamente fica
concentrado ali colesterol
ok não se assustem
aqui é só pra representar uma quantidade
x ac de crianças elas recebem tratamento
todos os dias pra pelo
internacionalmente aceito que são os
corticóides e os corticóides
eles atuam no sistema imunológico nas
células de defesa dessas crianças sendo
que acredita se que nestas crianças em
80 por cento dessas crianças
a origem da doença seja alguma célula de
algum fator circulante que ainda nem foi
identificado que esteja o sangue sendo
que elas são chamadas de códigos
sensíveis tanto que elas respondem bem
ao tratamento um corticosteróide agora
em 20% dos casos nós
temos crianças corte com resistentes ou
seja você os médicos dão tratamento dá
um tratamento elas não respondem elas
continuam com a doença
e essas crianças preocupam é lógico
porque elas não estão evoluindo bem
existe uma pesquisa intensa nessa ano
com relação a esse grupo e muitas
mutações em dna em vários genes de 40%
destas crianças vêm sendo identificadas
nos últimos 20 anos
só relembrando os no nosso dna é o
código de toda a estrutura do nosso
corpo então todas as estruturas cabelo
pele unha é órgãos internos são
produzidos pelo nosso dna
e não podia ser diferente com aquela
estrutura lá que eu coloquei na barreira
de filtração glomerular lembro que falei
dos poderosos que são importantíssimas
essa região na verdade é bem mais
complexa do que eu apresentei ela possui
toda essa estruturação sendo que todas
essas estruturas verdinho laranja
amarelo tudo ele é codificado pelo nosso
dna certo existem genes responsáveis
pela produção dessas estruturas e pela
com complexidade dessas estruturas
quando se encontra mutações em algum dos
genes que são responsáveis pela produção
dessa estrutura essa estrutura ficou
danificada e é isso que acontece na mãe
nesse grupo de pacientes que apresentam
mutações no seu dna
mas o que fazer todas todo o grupo tanto
os pórticos sensíveis quanto aos cortes
existentes recebem tratamento e vão
evoluir
alguma hora para insuficiência renal e
vão receber um transplante
então se vocês pensarem que aquelas
crianças que estão perdendo a função do
seu dna está perdendo a função da
peneira
elas recebem um novo que bom né
então agora o problema está resolvido
mas não no caso das caóticas sensíveis
porque estas apresenta um problema no
sangue que corrói de novo a estrutura
agora no caso das cortes existentes nas
quais a gente identifica mutações no dna
trocando a peneira elas vão ter o maior
benefício então trocou o órgão o
problema está resolvido para elas
então por isso que com maior segurança
antigos podem indicar um transplante
renal nestes casos aonde elas têm
mutações
além de que eles podem também retirar o
tratamento que estava sendo ineficaz
então está sendo uma excelente notícia
para médicos e pacientes com mutações
então essa boa notícia vinda hoje eu
gostaria de agradecer as médicas que
atendem diariamente essas crianças no
centro integrado de nefrologia doutora
vera belangero ana lu taiff é liliane
prates uma rigato ao departamento de
pediatria professor doutor gil guerra
júnior ao departamento de genética
professora doutora andréa maciel guerra
ea minha supervisora do trabalho silva
falando de melo do departamento de
genética humana da do centro de biologia
molecular e genética ea todos vocês
muito obrigado